الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه في مجلس الامن
القومي الامريكي ان الولايات المتحده
ستنظر في مجموعه من الادوات والخيارات
لاجبار الطرفين المتصارعين في السودان على
وقف القتال واكد كيربي في مؤتمر صحفي ان
التركيز منصب على حث الجانبين على التوصل
الى وقف اطلاق النار
مازلنا قلقين للغايه بشان العنف واستمرار
القتال وعدم صمود وقف اطلاق النار الليله
الماضيه ما يعني استمرار تعرض المدنيين
للاذى لن استبق اي قرارات بعقوبات او ما
شابه ذلك لكننا سننظر دائما في مجموعه من
الادوات والقدرات لدينا لنحاول اجبار كلا
الجانبين على وقف هذا العنف تركيزنا حاليا
منصب على حث كلا الجانبين على وقف العنف
والتوصل الى وقف اطلاق النار للسماح بوصول
المساعدات الانسانيه الى من هم بحاجه
اليها لان الوضع مريع في الخرطوم وهناك
بالفعل نقص في الغذاء والمياه والادويه
ان الرئيس بايدن وجه الجيش الامريكي
لارسال وحدات عسكريه لتمركز بالقرب من
السودان لاجلاء الرعايه الامريكيين حال
الاضطرار لذلك مشيرا الى اتصال بايدن
المنتظم بفريق الامن القومي لمعرفه ما
يدور في السودان
لديه اطلاع حديث على ما يدور من احداث في
الخرطوم وهو على اتصال منتظم بفريق الامن
القومي فيما يخص الاحداث في السودان منذ
بدء العنف هناك الرئيس بايدن اذن للجيش
بالمضي قدما في التمركز المسبق قريبا من
هناك وتوفير خيارات في حال اردنا واشدد
على في حال اردنا اجراء المواطنين من هناك